all right we are now live
for another political theory and
practice discussion
today we're going to be talking about
school reopenings in the time of covid19
mostly going to be focusing on my end on
what i know best the american situation
but of course we can talk about
what's going on internationally as well
so just a brief rundown of what i'm
going to do i'll talk for about
maybe 20 minutes or so give you some of
my thoughts
and some you know things to think about
some some issues to consider without
trying to provide
uh answers to everything in the first 20
minutes or so and then i'm just gonna
like
take uh questions comments and respond
to those
so the general issue is that of
reopening schools and when we say
schools we mean
k-12 education and we also mean higher
education that is colleges and
universities
in the time of covid19 so
there's a lot to be said about this i'm
obviously not going to try to cover
everything but but here's what we're
going to do we're going to think about
you know
what political theory is actually
applicable to this and i'm not
thinking so much that there's a single
idea like the social contract
to pick up on but rather a number of
different
concerns and we might do some theorizing
as we're going through this and
i think in this situation we're not
trying to find some sort of ideal
covers-everything solution we're sort of
looking for
least bad ways of doing things
i also think we need to discuss
especially for the international
audience
something that i've brought up a number
of times in these discussions
which is the particular situation that
we're in here
in the united states that i think a lot
of people from the outside
don't really understand or appreciate
they look at
our booming coronavirus cases they're
like what's going on there and they
don't understand
how failure of leadership on the federal
level
sometimes actually handicapping things
and coupled with our intense
localism has handicapped us in ways that
many other countries
are not facing certainly none of the
other developed countries
are are in in the same boat that we're
in so i
will talk about that a bit and then some
of the issues that i
wanted to get into in particular one is
analogous to that vietnam
war metaphor of destroying the village
to save it and i think something is
going on like that
sacrificing a generation in order to
save it in terms of education
we also need to talk about disadvantaged
and underserved
uh children and and populations groups
communities and the impact that
face-to-face
and online education has on them
i want to talk also about a
long-standing
lack of priority in in our spending
and our decision making here in the
united states when it comes to education
when it comes to the coming generations
and when it comes to all the other
things that are connected
with education like say child care
i think we also do need to talk about
the problem of leadership here in
america which is intensified by localism
uh particularly when it comes to
educational leadership
and then i do want to talk about the
social contract because there is indeed
an entire you know generation that we're
talking about here who
who does in large respect feel like the
social contract has been broken
for them here in america and that might
not be the case
in other places overseas and i mean my
students articulate this to me in in
classes when when we used to meet face
to face we
we do talk about this a little bit
actually we did talk about this in my
intro to philosophy class
with milwaukee institute of art and
design this this summer
so those are the big uh things i want to
talk about and also we could talk
about one other thing well what do you
do concretely given the screwed up
situation when kid
something that i'm actually facing with
one kid still down in indiana which is
not a good state for kovid not a good
state for education we'll talk about why
in a bit and the other coming up here to
university
of uh wisconsin milwaukee
where they've made some you know
remedies
uh some plans for kovid but none that
really seem adequate we're going to talk
about that as well
so before i jump into some some of these
these things
let's uh let me answer a question from
from mark smith
so the shirt is 414 which is the
milwaukee area code 414 justice
it's a shirt that that supports the
black lives matter
cause here in milwaukee we have had
marches and protests going on since the
very start as a matter of fact
one of our key organizers is currently
leading a march
from milwaukee to washington right now
uh they are somewhere i think in indiana
at this point
that's been going on for quite a while
so 414
is a is a milwaukee thing used to be the
local area code now it's the
the code for cell phones all right so so
let's talk a bit
uh about the conditions here in the
united states i i mentioned that we have
a
we have a tradition of localism and i
think a lot of people
don't they don't understand this from
the outside
so when it comes to policing when it
comes to prisons when it comes to
education when it comes to public health
there is no system people you know
who live in other more centralized
countries think well you can just like
you know fix
things from the top down and you can
sometimes do that
in america if you actually have
leadership at the top and we're lacking
that
and we'll talk about that in a moment
but in general we have this
long-standing tradition of
you know very localized institutions
that are you know serving communities
they all have their own budgets
they all have their own decision-making
processes so just to give you an
example here in wisconsin um
we had a statewide uh uh
you know masking social distancing
mandate
uh that the governor of wisconsin that's
the state that i live in
put out and the republicans who because
of gerrymandering
control the legislature even though they
only have about 44 percent of the
population
voting for them the democrats actually
had a greater majority
they control the legislature the the
republicans and they sued
to the state supreme court dominated by
republicans appointed by
uh previous republican governors who
viewed the mask
mandate as tyranny they were using this
sort of
crazy language and they they got it
quashed so
here in wisconsin from that point on it
was the wild west
any community could do anything it
wanted as far as masks as far as social
distancing
closing restaurants and bars people
streamed
up from from chicago to wisconsin to hit
the bars here
bringing kovid back home with them uh
here in milwaukee the largest city in
wisconsin
uh you know it's it's uh close to i
think 80
800 000 or so in the city and then we
have all these suburbs
here in milwaukee the health department
and the mayor
uh put in place some pretty stringent
requirements which are not being
followed unfortunately when it comes to
masks but are being followed when it
comes to restaurants
but one county over waukesha county
hardly anyone wears masks all sorts of
things are open
though the places that are actually
following good
mass protocol and social distancing are
uh corporate chains like chick-fil-a
you know because they they don't want to
get their workers sick and they have to
do business
outside of wisconsin say in places where
people are being more
more reasonable about this and so
you know when it comes to what we're
going to do about covid in general
it's totally up to the states it's
totally up to local municipalities some
states kicked it down like texas did for
a long time
to all the local counties some some
other states have
actually passed legislation or the
governor issued orders that would
prevent
local communities from exercising much
control
so that's like public health stuff when
it comes to education it's even worse
every little school is
part of either its own entity
or it's part of some larger entity which
is going to be
local and how these things are paid for
varies from state to state from county
to county
there are incredible disparities
in funding for education in the rules
for what's going to go on
um schools will typically have a school
board
and then there'll be a superintendent
and the superintendent might be hands-on
or the superintendent might be
you know a complete uh washout and then
there'll be a board for the
the county or the school district or in
indiana the school
corporation and so there's no uniformity
and what happens in one school
may be totally different from what
happens in another school
my kids down in indiana
in in two schools that were actually in
the same county
totally different calendars spring
breaks are at different times
you know how the teachers are treated
differently uh varies
you know so when it comes to covid
there's a lot of
uh variation between the schools some
are taking it very seriously some are
not
milwaukee public schools are not meeting
face-to-face
they are starting totally online and we
have some of the poorest zip codes in
the nation
in milwaukee but they're being served
because the milwaukee
uh uh you know public school you know
district has its proverbial crap
together
um that's not the case in many other
places and so we have incredible
challenges
in doing anything that's going to be
effective when it comes to these sorts
of issues putting aside covid19 even
when it comes to like
how should schools be run what should
day-to-day life look like what sort of
educational theories should be used what
textbooks should use
we have this patchwork of uh
it's like a mosaic it's not a map that's
unified
it's a little bit here and there and
here and there and here and there
and you can make some generalizations
you can say that you know
schooling in mississippi is in general
much worse than say here in wisconsin
but there are some school districts here
in wisconsin where it's as bad as
mississippi
and there are some good places in
mississippi usually where they have
plenty of
money so this is um
something that needs to be addressed now
barklord has a thing here
education is paid by local property
taxes some of it is
some of it isn't some of it comes from
the states some of it comes from grants
some of it comes from this
you cannot generalize that's that's part
of the problem
you can't just say oh it's all local
property taxes
that's part of it but that's only a
little bit of it
there's so many there's so many moving
parts so when it comes to
doing things to protect children and to
protect other people from covid
some schools are doing a good job some
schools are doing an incredibly mediocre
job
when it comes to higher education we're
in the same boat as well
there are regional accrediting bodies
some of which are actually quite lacks
i i am very unimpressed with middle
states
and with north central but by comparison
to sacs which is the
uh one that covers southern universities
and colleges i've seen places where
the uh you know essentially the the
proposals and plans that are
provided to these educational uh uh
um overseers are fiction
and nobody actually checks on it we also
have over 2 000 institutes of higher
education
some of our some of them are part of
state organizations right they're part
of the state schools i mentioned my
daughter's going to uw
milwaukee that's university of
wisconsin-milwaukee
but what happens in uw-milwaukee can be
totally different from what happens in
uw
oshkosh totally different from stevens
point we add in all these other schools
just here in the milwaukee area
we have university of
wisconsin-milwaukee we have marquette
university
we have mount mary we have milwaukee
school of engineering
uh milwaukee institute of art design
milwaukee area technical college all of
these
totally different organizations totally
different entities
all of which are setting their own sort
of thing marquette is opening
face-to-face i don't think they're going
to remain open
face-to-face uw-milwaukee is opening
face-to-face
milwaukee institute of art and design
opening face to face but
in a very restricted way and they've got
some really
serious plans in place milwaukee area
technical college
opening face-to-face only for lab and
practicum classes and studio classes
but i think that their plans are not
really going to work and they are
a really dysfunctional institution when
it comes to planning and stuff like that
so i think they're going to have some
real trouble
arising plus they're they're often
serving underserved students so there's
gonna be a lot of people falling through
the cracks despite our best efforts
so and this is just in the milwaukee
area we could expand it to the rest of
wisconsin we could expand it to the rest
of the nation
we are a mess when it comes to this
and when you read their covid plans
which i've been doing because i i'm
privy to emails from
oh about five different institutions of
higher learning
you you read these plans and some of
them you're like well that's going to
work but that's not going to work
no way all it's going to take is a
couple frat boys who don't want to
follow the rules
and you're going to have a covet
outbreak or pick whoever else you want
as
sort of like lazy slobs who who think
that they're entitled to not follow
protocols or don't take things seriously
it doesn't have to be
frat boys it could be anybody else you
like
now we've got some serious issues here
so the localism thing is a big
problem um
lack of leadership from on top normally
you know
the department of health and human
services would be heavily involved the
cdc would be heavily involved
department of education would be heavily
involved but under the trump
administration unfortunately
um where you know cronyism and
corruption is the name of the game
these are very ineffective you know um
you can bet that
somebody like betsy devos is not going
to do anything to help anybody she's not
an educator she doesn't know anything
about education
she was a big donor and she got put in
charge of the department of education
because that's the kind of
that's the kind of show that this
administration is running
so we're in some serious problems
when it comes to leadership we also have
a problem with local leadership so
what i'm going to say here will probably
offend some people
and i'm generalizing there are some
really good
superintendents high school principals
you know people in charge of higher
education
but for the most part they're garbage
they're not well educated
they don't know much about education
other than what they took in educational
leadership classes
some of them have never stepped foot in
a classroom some of them haven't been
teaching for years and years
and you know it's amazing when you deal
with high school principles
how dumb some of them actually are
and these are the people making the
decisions you're like
how did you not predict this how did you
not think about this you know
and i i can say this as a parent i can
say this is somebody who's done
you know a lot of engagements with with
other educators don't take for granted
that your
your you know educational leadership
team at any given place
actually know what they're doing or have
good character or are ethical or
pick any of these sorts of things that
you want we can't predict that and it
varies from place to place to place to
place
now unfortunately we're stuck in a
situation where if people screw up over
here
it might have impacts on other people
over over here
so that's some of the situation in the
u.s i'm going to run through some of
these
issues pretty pretty quickly there is
this really interesting discussion
that's happening where over and over
again people are saying oh there's
a danger of significant learning losses
that's the catchphrase that's being used
by
educational experts and leaders if we
don't go
face to face here's something worth
thinking about
is this a sort of like i said a let's
destroy the village to save the village
sort of thing
are you actually getting good education
from a masked up teacher
in a socially distanced classroom where
you can't really hear people and the
events have to be running
all the time and we're so distracted by
trying to follow
all these protocols do you think that's
going to be
you know significant learning going on
there in these face-to-face classes if
you do
you're you're probably you want to
rethink that
it's probably better to actually have
online
opportunities for learning the other
thing too is somebody pointed out in
twitter and this is just brilliant
you know having your parent die on you
because you brought covid home
probably a bigger blow to your education
than missing some months of school
you know i can tell you somebody whose
dad died
uh well i you know in between the summer
of sixth and seventh grade
that that really did affect my school
performance
and it also affected me emotionally and
i don't know how much
damage it did to me i certainly did a
lot of damage to my sister she never
graduated from high school
it screwed her up so much in so many
different ways
other family dynamics stuff so the idea
that
we're just going to send these kids off
and then everything's going to be great
we're going to follow these rules
none of the parents are going to get
sick none of the none of the teachers
this is just pipe dream stuff you know
and so i think we really need to be
thoughtful we ought we have a we have a
duty
a moral duty to think about what's
actually good for these students when
we're making decisions for them
or at least the people who are making
those decisions ought to those of us who
can advocate
to do that we also have this big problem
of underserved and disadvantaged kids
and communities
so as a laptop like the one i mod at
home
here we go we just had a
internet outage right there right so you
can have internet interruptions
some places like milwaukee area
technical college are expanding their
wi-fi
so that students can actually come over
by the school
and use the school's wi-fi but that's
that's one of the
key things that we can do
there's a lot of danger of of the kids
who are
not in the rich school districts who are
who are struggling falling through the
cracks and we have to
devote resources to that instead of you
know bailouts for big corporations
maybe that's where some of the money
ought to be going to um
this leads me to another point the lack
of priority given to education
and to children in general in the united
states we give a lot of lip service to
you know
excellence and we're going to like
prepare people for 21st century jobs
most of that is smoke and mirrors
very few people know what's going on
with education
um there's there's a lot of uh you know
compared to other places
we're not getting much uh bang for the
buck for the money that we spend on
education
and we're not doing it very well and
part of this is that incredible localism
and part of it is terrible leadership on
top from both the the you know trump
administration
and some previous administrations and
congress so there's some real
issues there um
this leads me to the last thing and
we're getting close to the time
actually we're over the time that i
spent that i was gonna talk about
there there's a risk of a completely
broken social contract
i think that for young people in
generation z and the very last of the
millennials
we can talk about people making vast
decisions for them
and putting them at risk in many
different ways claiming to care about
them but not
really doing so i'll just give you a few
examples of pre-coveted stuff that were
driving this home and my students were
talking about this with me
gun violence totally you know totally
ineffective
controls on that here in the united
states fortunately the nra is finally
under attack
because they've been allowed to
short-circuit things for so long and the
republicans and many democrats
went along with them uh essentially
whoring themselves out for
for campaign money um funding
and inequalities we have massive
inequalities when it comes to education
here in the united states
many students can look at their schools
and say i've been i've been kind of hung
out to dry
and that's not just a this generation
thing that's a previous generation thing
and that was also going on from my
generation as well
this whole notion of like preparing
people for 21st century jobs
most of the people talking about that
don't have a clue about what these 21st
century jobs are
students just find out that they're they
can't take these classes they have to
take these classes instead
and that they have to do a lot of
standardized testing in order you know
to make things work
and all that these are all just things
that were already there for students
now students can look at their their uh
you know educational institutions and
the politicians and say
wow these people do not care about us
they're hanging us out to dry
they don't care if we get sick they
don't care if we get our parents sick
they don't care if we get our
teachers sick they're cool with that so
long as they can say that they've
accomplished opening or you know and
it's it's clear when you see these sorts
of things
one of the schools that you know i gave
you in the reading list
they say they can't enforce mask
mandates right they're socially
distancing
they're not socially distancing they
took pictures of that school the kids
are like
you know right up on top of each other
and they're not wearing masks and the
reason they're not wearing masks
is because the school says despite the
fact that they can
impose a dress code mostly falling on
the girls
and they can like expel students for
that they
wearing a mask is a personal choice
students
are seeing through this [ __ ] and
they're saying wow these people
do not care they care about other things
more than they care about us
and that's a real problem so let's uh
let's take some of these questions and
comments
um so mark starts out by saying
how would you articulate the distinction
between the ethical and the legal
as people seem to conflate the two
i ask because it seems this issue around
schools might cause a potential clash
between what rules demand and
versus what the ethical choice might be
part of the problem is that the rules in
many cases
are um not the right rules
you know like like i just pointed out
with that school if they if they can
enforce the dress code
right and they can police whether girls
are showing shoulder or something like
that they sure as hell can say
mask up dummy you know uh or whatever
you want to say to some kid who doesn't
want to wear a mask or wants to
wear it you know not over their nose
it's it's the administrators who don't
want to do it it's the
the you know the people in charge who uh
gripped by an ideology essentially um
because it's clear
even if you thought that masks aren't
really going to help
in a major way it's the right thing to
do
you know um you you even even if it
turned out like
with a pascal's wager that masking up
didn't really affect anything since we
don't know
or since you know we do actually know
because the studies have shown they are
effective but let's say you didn't know
it would be the right thing to do
right and washing your hands i mean you
know it's amazing
this is a little bit of a rant it's
amazing that people are resistant
to the idea of washing their hands in
basic personal hygiene because someone
else told them to
this is a real problem here in america
this sort of like
ma freedom you know my liberties sort of
nonsense that we've got i don't know
what we're going to do about it but
all right uh let's see here
skip says glad you've been keeping these
going yeah yeah i'm
i i think it's a good thing to do uh
here we go from logan
do you think compulsory in-person
lecture class attendance is necessary
for education
similar to compulsory mask mandate
necessary for reducing coronavirus cases
so that's a
great question and the answer is no
we've been doing online education
some people rather poorly but some of us
very conscientiously and well
for decades it's been going on for
decades
and it's been getting better and better
and better there are entire
organizations out there like quality
matters
devoted solely to reviewing
online education classes and curricula
and saying
hey you should fix this hey this is the
best practices over here
no you you don't have to have in-person
classes
for everybody now not everybody is is
cool with online education right
some people genuinely do need to have
the face-to-face thing and i like
teaching face-to-face classes
i kind of miss being there with the
students
and getting to be in the same room and
stuff like that but i also recognize
that that's not absolutely necessary
i will say this online education
requires different skills and different
approaches than face-to-face the people
who think that it's just about having
zoom meetings
and you know uh putting a few exercises
online they don't actually understand
online education
and if they think that's what the case
then they should just sit down and shut
up and not talk about it right
and and let the the people who do know
about it um be the
the opinion formers and policy makers
again good reason why betsy devos should
not be in charge of the department of
education she doesn't have a clue
about teaching or education right we
should have somebody in there who's an
actual educator
who can um lead and
and you know promote the right policies
we don't actually unfortunately have a
compulsory mask mandate
that's being followed even here in
milwaukee we have a mandate but
it's not being enforced so i don't think
that there's a direct analogy between
those but we do
we do need to think about um
why it is that people are so insistent
on face-to-face classes
and maybe that's we can come back to
that in a bit
all right uh
skip uh rightly so i personally feel no
loss of freedom while wearing a mask
yeah i mean here's the thing if you
actually feel like your rights or your
freedom are being impinged
upon by wearing a mask during a
pandemic you've got some psychological
problems
that you really want to take a look at
that's
that's what i would say um you know
probably debilitating ones if you feel
that great
of an outrage or fear or you know any of
these
emotional responses to wearing a piece
of fabric in front of your face
which may in fact keep you from getting
sick and may keep your loved ones from
getting sick
and will certainly conduce to an
environment of less people getting sick
if you don't want to do that you're
basically an [ __ ]
you know what however you come down to
it and you could be an
[ __ ] because you just like to be an
[ __ ] or you could be an [ __ ]
because of fear
or because of you know some weird
ideology of personal freedom and this is
tyranny
but that's really what it comes down to
um and these people who are hysterics
and they say oh i
i put a mask on and i walked around and
i started
getting out of breath i walk around here
in milwaukee and i'm a fat guy who's in
is almost almost 50 years old
uh walking around in 90 degree heat with
a mask over my face
walking five miles and it doesn't bother
me
you know i mean the mask gets all sweaty
and stuff sure
that's a minor inconvenience that's
because i've got this big thick beard
here
right but these these hysterics
who say i put on a mask and i had
trouble breathing this is nonsense
and and we really shouldn't take any of
those people seriously
other than to tell them to get them
psychological help i think
um zeno how do we incentivize better
leadership in public education
i don't know um i don't know that we can
incentivize it
i think part of what we need to do at
this point
it's a great question we do need to
think about that long term i think what
we need to do right now
is a lot of pushback i think we need to
demand that that
educational leadership be accountable
and i think that we need to do whatever
it takes to get the
the bad leaders out and then so that's
sort of a very short term
strategy and then when we have you know
more time we can think about how do we
get good leaders in
part of that is is thinking about what
characteristics we want in leaders
so in terms of universities i would say
that one of the things we want to think
about
is leaders who are not just about the
bottom line
because a lot of these people who are
you know president
chancellor um vp
dean level the deans are often in small
places
promoted from from the faculty but in a
lot of places they're they're not
and so all these executive leadership
positions
they're mostly people who are about you
know budgets
keeping the bottom line going and in the
case of presidents schmoozing to bring
in money for the university
so um we want people who have genuine
educational experience and we want
people who
are ethical that means that they're
going to be
caring about the students more than
they're caring about the financial
bottom line of the university especially
if they've got big endowments
you know i don't want to see
universities that have
uh you know 100 million dollar
endowments
telling us that they can't do this or
that
you know they probably also need to
start putting money away for a rainy day
so that they're not so radically
dependent on
people being in the dorms and they need
to quit spending money on [ __ ]
things maybe they need to quit spending
money on athletics
so much and start firing some of the
head coaches and getting cheaper ones
you know
the alumni might not like it but you
know if you're in leadership you're
there to do the tough decisions not
not just the easy ones maybe we
shouldn't be spending so much on new
dorms maybe we should be
focusing on how we're going to you know
reconfigure classrooms and build out i.t
structures so that the next pandemic
we're not faced with this problem so
those are some of the things i think we
need with leadership when it comes down
to k-12 man that's a tough one
because you don't need quite so much to
become a principal
or a superintendent a lot of it is about
personal contacts and
you know hanging out with the right
people and being friends with
politicians
but it totally depends on the area that
you're in
and i mean i'll put it to you this way
we actually
have uh people who are educational
leaders
uh in our building and who don't wear
masks
in our building in milwaukee you know
and you're like
what in the hell are these people
thinking so you know
i think there's a lot of criteria that
we can come up with for what good
educational leadership would look like
but right now our goal should be on
getting the the people who are
ineffective
getting them out or at least putting
pressure on them to become more
effective
all right um
sam says is a political theory means
just a
philosophical position hypothesis or
s-t-h like that or s-t-h-l
i'm not sure what that's actually meant
but
um political theory is is not a single
meaning term it covers a wide range uh
and i mean it's been around for a very
long time hey political episteme
aristotle called it right
uh the science of politics or the
discipline of politics
and so it can cover you know very
uh abstract discussions all the way down
to
you know the sort of things that we're
talking about here
gutter says people say it's about the
kids education but that's a euphemism
for free babysitting
i would avoid any sort of sweeping
statements like that
um when it comes this incredible
patchwork so you can't really even
effectively generalize about education
in the united states
but even so if you just focused on one
school
i'm willing to bet that there's plenty
of parents and teachers and kids for
whom it's not just free babysitting
so those sort of comments are not
particularly uh productive
that said uh if we if we change it a
little bit
there is a really significant issue at
play
it's not about babysitting it's about
child care
and the issue is this
if we're having kids stay home from
school
rather than going off to school where
they have the you know risk of of
getting
infection or carrying infection home
we do need to to address the issue of
how these kids are going to get not just
a productive
education at home but what to do with
all the parents who
still have to go out to work if you're a
janitor cleaning up at
one of these schools or cleaning up at a
hospital so you're an essential employee
right
and your kid uh he has to do online
education because they're in the
milwaukee public schools and they
haven't yet
moved back to hybrid and face to face
because we're not at the point with
coronavirus where we can
what do you do you just leave your kid
at home and say all right johnny
uh go to it i mean that might work with
a 12 year old
um i mean i grew up in the generation
where we were called latchkey kids for a
reason right
because we were on our own a lot of the
time because oftentimes both parents or
single parents worked
um but i don't know about like a
six-year-old
you know you've got to have somebody
watching them so this this is a genuine
issue
i just wouldn't put it in such a
demeaning term as babysitting
i would call it child care and i would
say that this ought to be
a major uh priority for us
right this this is a priority for
um not just government but also
education and also
corporations all right um
zeno says i didn't notice much of a
difference in my learning shifting to
online
that said most of my classes are
humanities and social science
yeah you know so again use my daughter
as an example
she signed up for five classes at
university of wisconsin-milwaukee and
she is a musical theater
major and like one of her classes
is an honors class sort of like a
humanities class
another i think is like history of
theater those both went online
and i'm like totally happy i i don't
want her being any more put at risk
than than she has to her other three
classes right now are still face to face
in part because they involve movement
right so like
she's got a ballet class it's kind of
hard to do that online
you know and this is why places like
milwaukee institute of art design and
milwaukee area technical
college have said studio classes
practicum classes like those that nurses
do
and lab classes will probably still have
to be face to face for the time being
now that may change as well
so yeah there are some things that are
very easy to put online
the kind of stuff that i do philosophy
classes humanities classes
uh critical thinking religious studies
that's pretty easy to do online
i don't know how you do a
class that requires a lot of interaction
close interaction between teachers and
students about physical objects
i don't know how you shift that online
as easily and maintain a lot
but we we can do what we can
mark says a lot of solid effort here in
south africa by universities to
cooperate with big tech firms to provide
better internet computer access to less
privileged students
setting a good precedent moving forward
that is that is really great to hear
especially since you know south africa i
think we can say
is still a developing country a lot of
populations i mean
one of the interesting things in the uh
um
uh one of the the sources that i gave
you i'm blanking on on the title of it
but it's about uh
things worldwide it's talking about
india right internet access is a real
problem in india
a lot of people don't have access to it
or they don't have reliable access or
they don't have devices that that can be
effective for education you know you can
do education on a phone but i think a
tablet
is way more helpful and a laptop is
is even better so you know
we don't have anything like that
unfortunately here in the united states
again
lack of leadership on the top too much
localism
massive inequality maybe corporations
are the people that need to do that
retro gamer says thanks again for my
uh amazing philosophy teaching output
enjoying the return of my hegel lectures
very much
thanks and thanks for the the uh little
contribution there a little bit of a
birthday gift i'll i'll call it
okay so my birthday's in uh nine days
from now
turning 50. never thought i'd be this
old man
right back back to this all right uh
and foamy this may sound sci-fi but if
you could
oh this is interesting this is a really
interesting idea
this may sound sci-fi but if you could
replace advertisements with
educational facts force businesses to
use their packages to help with
education
okay so you know educational facts
that's bits of information
and obviously that's not the same thing
as an education
but it sure would be
helpful wouldn't it i mean it gives you
a lot more to work with
let's say it was like today it's going
to be history facts right and
and a lot of history stuff is like
people
um finding out that they they didn't
learn
this thing over here like for example
i'll give you a fact about
uh wisconsin did you know that wisconsin
almost seceded from the uh union
prior to the civil war it wasn't just
the southern states that wanted to
secede
it was our sixth governor uh randall
alexander
who is a very strong uh
abolitionist and he said if lincoln
doesn't win
this 1860 election we're out of here
wisconsin
and um obviously lincoln did win and
wisconsin contributed more than its fair
share of uh
troops to the war to fight the
southerners who were seceding
but now did you know about that i
actually found out about that by
seeing a plaque about a terrible
accident that killed a whole bunch of
people coming up from chicago
they were coming up from chicago to stir
up trouble here in milwaukee
about this secession problem right and
then i started reading about randall
alexander and i was like wow that's cool
so you know if these facts could spur
further like if they included a thing
like click here for more information
that would be amazing wouldn't it if
corporations even did that half the time
like if we said hey if you want to
advertise you can advertise
but half to one third of your
advertisements actually have to be like
public service announcements that will
be about
learning another uh thing that got
brought up recently
you know what if and apparently mexico
is doing this what if we just like
ran um lectures uh
and they could be fairly we could make
them interactive in certain ways by the
way that you design
lectures what if we just ran those on on
television stations like 24
7 and kids could tune in to them you
know if they're stuck home from school
and some some older people when i posted
that
uh because i'm not i didn't i didn't
post that as my proposal
somebody else had proposed that and i
was like this is a great idea
and i remember there being things like
that on pbs
the previous generation boomers here in
milwaukee at least
on channel 10 they used to have
educational programming like that
that by the way was the initial idea
behind television that it would be an
educational thing
not just about you know streaming
reality tv and talk shows and stuff like
that but actual
education so all right
um tice says i agree entirely i saw this
wonderful diagram of morality
oh yes you're thinking of the venn
diagram conscient utilitarian virtue
ethics
they all came to the same conclusion put
a mask on yes that's
i mean that's quite correct the only
thing that would would really
uh the only moral theories that would
would be against that
would be a weird variety of
libertarianism that that
had zero connection with sort of like
social or public interest or pure egoism
you know
um ah so banda
banakazui says what do you think about a
24-hour government television program
for education something like sesame
street for high school
yes that is exactly what we were just
talking about a minute ago
i think that you know that that should
be something that we could produce
you think about how inexpensive that
sort of thing is to to produce
compared to the high production for
the bs that's on tv most of the time you
know
it's it's it's easy you and you've got
like a
a ton of people who could go on tv shows
granted
some of them would not be very good you
weed them out right you get the ones
you know there's there's probably
thousands of lamar burtons out there
uh who could be tapped and um you know
let's say you pay them good money
hundred grand a year
right um you're not paying them like
what you pay
actors and actresses in hollywood um
just you know pay them something decent
and good health care and stuff like that
and then they get to talk about their
passion whether it's you know
bugs or you know finances or whatever
it would be amazing we could we could
easily do this and the government could
pay for it
if we didn't have so many people who are
like oh i don't want the government
involved in this sort of thing you know
um yeah all right uh
ron says why do you think conservatives
have been so bad when it comes to
wearing masks combating the virus in
general
when they're so vigilant when it came to
countering the terrorism after 9 11. so
i'm going to say something paradoxical
conservatives most conservatives those
who call themselves conservatives are
not conservative at all
they are authoritarian and they are
libertarian
in weird ways they're not really
conservative because
genuine conservatives would give a [ __ ]
about their community
want it safe and healthy and would be
doing their best
to try to preserve some sort of common
good
does that map on to most people that
call themselves conservatives today
not really there's a lot of uh
group think on on their part i would say
just as much as we can find
in the left and center left uh you know
there's probably some people who are
wearing masks just because all their
neighbors are
and uh because they think it's the you
know trendy thing to do and something
like that
and there's a lot of people who are not
wearing masks because they don't have
the balls to actually
like do the right thing when their
neighbors aren't doing the right thing
you know and then there's a lot of them
who are engaging in kind of wishful
thinking there's this desire to return
to normalcy
a normal that was never really that good
except for
a few people and um
you know then there's the whole you know
this is tyranny sort of nonsense
i mean one of our supreme court justices
an educated woman
presumably um actually used the word
tyranny to talk about the governor
saying people should wear masks that's
insane
she should be committed you know for
writing
something like that that's not
conservative at all
that's just some weird whacked out
you know morphed from the tea party into
trumpism
sort of thing and you know the real
issue is how are we going to get these
people out of this
you know what's going to happen to them
this party is not going to hold on to
power forever
um what are we gonna do with all these
people who have like
essentially engaged in a big group
brainwashing session with each other
for for years and years now about these
these crazy talking points
all right um
let's see what else we got here
id says uh the people nodding along to
new york times anti-racist hysteria in
the official months of january february
have now successfully framed themselves
as moral authorities it's disgusting
what's truly amazing the democrats have
forgotten it's their sick globalist
ideology
you know when you start spouting stuff
like that i don't take you seriously at
all i just i read that and i'm like
i don't know what the hell you're doing
here obviously uh you know
uh you're you're just trolling so
um all those things like globalist
that's a substitute for thought
you label people like that all right um
let's see here zeno says what are my
thoughts on universities charging the
same tuition for online education
is there any justification for this or
are they just being greedy yeah there's
a justification
to begin with tuition is tuition room
and board is for staying on campus
you want to pay for the college
experience that comes out of your room
and board
if you think that face-to-face classes
masked up trying to like stick to you
know
corridors that you're supposed to walk
in during times
and like sitting uh you know hopefully
at least six feet away from your fellow
students
is going to be the same college
experience that people are
used to that you're used to paying for
and that online education done well is
somehow
not as good man
that's that's a stretch um now
you know saying that uh the sort of
pivot to online was just as good as
face no it wasn't because a lot of
instructors don't know how to teach
online
some of us have been doing it for almost
a decade
people try you know my online courses
fill up
very quickly because people know they're
going to be better
than a lot of the face-to-face classes
that are being offered what we need to
do is train up a whole
hundred people who can do online
education well
and that is worth paying for what i
think is is ridiculous
is the fact that when i teach for
marquette
now i'm going to let you in on a little
bit of the economics of
teaching as an adjunct and and the money
that they're making as an adjunct
when i teach for marquette um i get paid
around a little over four thousand bucks
for the class
each student in that class is being
charged 4
500 bucks for the class so you can tell
it's not going to professor salaries
by the way professors at marquette not
being hired at
really high rates um some of them are
being hired at as low as
uh um 37.5
per year so that money is going into the
administrator
administrations paying for new buildings
new gyms athletic programs all that sort
of stuff
right those students are paying four
thousand
five hundred dollars for that class
whether it's online or
face-to-face it's my online class it's
good
it's my face-to-face it's good at
milwaukee area technical college
they're paying you know um
not i wouldn't say ten percent of that
but maybe fifteen percent of that
now i'm not getting paid as much to
teach a class at milwaukee area
technical college they paid me about
3 000 a class there um
at carthage like at 3 500 a class
to teach that class to design it teach
it build it you know
turn in the grades and each of those
students is probably getting charged
about
3 800 for that class now
it depends it doesn't matter whether
it's online or face-to-face
uh is this a good system where this the
the
i'm teaching the same class for uh
marquette as i'm teaching for carthage
as i'm teaching for
milwaukee area technical college i don't
like you know skimp on the
matc students as a matter of fact i'm
teaching some in prisons
right uh through that they're all
getting really the same class experience
except you know maybe it's a little bit
nicer on marquette or carthage campus
carthage is a beautiful campus
is this fair the students don't really
know about this until i tell them about
that they also don't know that most of
the money isn't going to paying the
professor
but rather getting siphoned off and all
these other things
i don't think that we ought to be saying
i don't think i don't think the
conversation really ought to be
you know should we pay just as much for
online as we do
for uh face-to-face i think the
conversation should be
should we pay as much for this either
kind
as we do for for this you know is is
marquette education
really that more valuable than matc is
i don't think so so yeah
all right uh bug
going to be hard to put wood shop class
online yeah that's that's that's a tough
one
uh and and you know if you'd said um i
mean
you could say marginally if it metal
shop class but even metal
has weird impurities and it's good to
have somebody looking at it and saying
hey this is how you got to fix this sort
of thing my great uncle hubert was a
master welder and i have two
two family members currently right now
in the ironworkers union down in indiana
and stuff that they do is pretty amazing
you know
it's tough to teach that sort of thing
without face-to-face interaction
but people do learn through youtube
tutorials
so all right um
retro gamer happy birthday dr sandler
congratulations on your longevity
yeah hopefully i'll make it like another
30 or so you know maybe maybe longer
it's kind of sad to think that maybe the
majority of my years are behind me and i
probably pissed a lot of them away
doing dumb stuff but
you know that's that's the way it is for
so many of us
right um
let's see here jb says
uh 50 is survivable we've had irrational
exuberance in british columbia oh
it's too bad where we had cases down to
just over 10 a day back in june but now
we're back to 50
plus any philosophy that helps with this
backlash
yeah i mean i think a lot of this is one
of those things where i forget who's
just pointing it out the venn diagram
right
with uh ethics you know virtue ethics
deontology utilitarianism wear a mask
right
i think when it comes to philosophies
that provide an intentional way
of living
whether it be you know platonic
aristotelian stoic
you know christian philosophers who have
a bent like that like boethius or
augustine or anselm
um or even epicureans um
they all provide us with some sort of
thing some sort of techniques that help
us
deal with living in a
irrational world rationality stems from
other people and their bad
decision-making processes
and it also helps us look within and
find our own uh
you know irrationalities and conflicts
that we might want to
not just look at but start working on so
like we don't get so pissed off when
people do dumb stuff you know
we don't need to respond necessarily in
that way
you know like seneca says in on anger
anything that we can do
with anger if we're properly trained we
can do with practical reason
and then we don't have all of the
baggage that comes with anger
like spillover and targeting the wrong
people
and all those sorts of things so
all right uh gotham what's the science
about kids being vectors of covet i've
seen articles that kids aren't good
vectors of the disease and that they're
good enough vectors to
increase copious spread substantially um
there's two things you need to think
about one is kids getting infected
the other is kids just not washing their
frickin hands
and you know touching the same rails and
coming into the house and bringing that
crap
in right so and it's not just the kids
getting infected
at schools you need to think about uh
the
staff you you know uh whether it's
secretaries or
lunch people or custodians you need to
think about the teachers
all of those matter as well we do know
that for like k
through 12 except taking high schoolers
out of there who seem
some of the science seems to show that
high schoolers are are
you know getting more and more
susceptible makes sense because they're
getting closer to being adults right
um but let's say we take elementary
school kids okay so not that many of
them are going to get sick
and and many of them are probably going
to have good prospects
then again if only like say 0.1 percent
of them get sick
and you're the one who made the decision
about that and you have a
school district that has a thousand kids
in it you've said that
it's okay for that kid to get sick and
maybe die from it you know
um that's we we really ought to be sort
of doing
what we call uh uh what is it
is it minimax or maximizing let's get
those two mixed up we should be reducing
the amount of risk possible
right and then when it comes to high
schoolers when it comes to college age
kids
it goes further up i mean we're going to
see
so the high school that made the news
because they had all these people packed
in
they already have a number of kids
high school kids who have who have now
tested positive for covid
and three staff just within like a week
right what's it gonna be like a month
from now so
these are the things we want to think
about
all right let's see here
what else have we got um
just skipped a little bit ah
gooder ground having education online
for free to use is a necessary
prerequisite for post scarcity
yeah that that's true it may be
a necessary prerequisite even if we
don't go the post-scarcity route
and we're talking about here
post-scarcity refers to a future where
we're not all having to work
and as a matter of fact many of us won't
have to work um
and our basic needs would all be
provided for and we wouldn't be like you
know competing for them or stuff like
that
so to some people this is very utopian
uh but that may be where we're
we're headed i mean ideally that would
be great one of the things that we do
need to think about is well what do we
do with people
human beings when they're no longer
working
and no longer engaging like that do we
just like
let them sit around and play video games
all day and eat chips and
i guess take walks and zoom with each
other once in a while
uh or is that sort of lifestyle gonna
not work for a lot of people and they're
gonna be like i need some excitement
let's bust some stuff up you know
education could be a major part of that
but i think even if we
even if we don't have a a good
post-scarcity future
we have something that's a bit more
dystopian you're gonna need some
education
uh and it's probably gonna have to be
free you know
all right um
retro gamer aha but the institution is
doing the marketing to get the students
for your class
oh yeah sure um and the marketing is
sometimes done well
the marketing is sometimes done poorly
um
but the marketing can be done you know
fairly cheaply you know if when i was
teaching for
for marist college and i was teaching
online
the reason why you know the reason why
most of these educational institutions
got into online teaching
in the first place was not actually
because they love people and they want
to expand access
and they care so much about their
students it was economic
it was a k what we call a cash cow same
thing by the way when i was teaching in
the prison system
i'll tell you about the prison system
first so when i was teaching for ball
state
university in indiana state prison um
only and i'd have 20 students in a class
two of those students were paying for my
salary the rest were paying for other
stuff let you know the use of the prison
and all that
10 of them were pure profit pure
profit the school was like making tons
of money on top of that
that's why ball state had 120 120
professors
in the prisons you know kaching it's the
same thing for online education
the reason why marist college and
marquette
later on and all these other places got
into online education is because
it is so incredibly cost effective
and they realize that you know do you
actually
need um buildings
now you might need an office what you
really need are servers
and that's not that expensive and you
need it staff and you need people who
are trained to do that
uh teaching online and stuff like that
now granted physical stuff
sure but if you actually look at where a
lot of the money in the universities has
gone into it's not gone into their
classrooms for humanities classes
it's gone into new athletic facilities
it's going into souped-up dorms
and and cafeterias it's gone into
administrator salaries
and it's gone into paying coaches lots
of money
so you know for the face-to-face classes
you can say yeah they're providing the
infrastructure
some of the money that you're you're
making for them goes to pay for that
infrastructure the rest goes to all
these parasites
you know or unnecessary building
projects
where the money's never going to be
gotten back so
yeah i mean we could do a whole thing
about the economics of education here in
the united states that i think would be
kind of mind-blowing especially for
people
not from the states um all right let's
see what else we've got here
uh gutter says marginal cost of
distribution is near zero once content
is created
yeah i think that's that's uh i mean
that's true you do need to update things
every once in a while you have like you
know preserving
the uh digital content because it does
sometimes degrade
um but you're right it is pretty pretty
low
um now that's not to say that you know a
lot of people are worried that oh
if i record content then i'm going to be
replaced
no man not if you're a good teacher if
you actually interact with your students
in a regular way
students do still crave some some in a
one-on-one time or
12 on one time or or even 50 on one time
with an instructor who cares about their
topic and can talk about them
uh you know with some passion and and
some
competence and who's going to you know
help them along their educational
journey so
yeah um
jb says interesting parallels here with
publishing ebook versus print
self-publishing lots of people think
that ebooks should be really cheap
but actually the main cost is not
materials
yeah i guess that was that was a that's
true
uh you're paying for you're kind of
paying for talent
right uh now that means a lot of ebooks
probably ought to be really cheap
because some of them are not very good
so um in textbooks man
this is a whole different talking point
textbooks ought to be way cheaper than
they are because they mostly suck
but the textbook manufacturers really
jack up the prices on them
you know i was looking at um so i'm
teaching medical ethics this this fall
and i haven't taught medical ethics for
a long time
and uh i had to look at textbooks that i
was going to use
for this class for carthage college and
holy crap are those textbooks expensive
and so i went with something really
inexpensive
uh paperback it's still 50 bucks for the
the students unfortunately and they
won't even send the the company won't
even send me a
physical copy myself they just gave me
an e-book for it so i'm gonna have to
buy a copy
myself all right um
jb says uh authors cut and traditional
publishing is small
but you get advertising and so on from
that that
though unless nowadays um authors have
to self-promote yeah even if you're
with so we're getting a little bit
outside of the educational field but
even if you're like if you even if
you're doing something with one of the
big publishers
you as the author have to go out and and
promote and as a matter of fact
when you write a book proposal they want
to see that you've got a social media
presence and that you have an ability to
promote your book
they don't want to take a chance on you
unless they think they're going to
get you to do that sort of stuff so
all right um
xeno why is philosophy not taught in the
k-12 system is a necessary course yeah
that's a great question so it is in in
some countries
um you know france is a prime example
you know portugal is another great
example some of my videos are used in uh
resources for the porsche portuguese
national curriculum
um we don't do that here in the united
states
if you do get a philosophy class it'll
either be because you're in a religious
school
and it usually gets taught as a religion
elective which doesn't mean it's getting
taught in a religious
way it just means that's how they do it
or you're in a rich public school and it
gets taught as a humanities or social
sciences elective
and we just don't have it because it's
never been there
as part of the k-12 education for public
schools
it should have been i mean i don't know
why
i i don't know that much about the
history of that
quite frankly and i should dig into that
now it's too hard to get new stuff into
the school
unless you can like give an example of
exactly how it's going to pay off
for the students and job you know
vocational stuff
so it can be taught as an elective and
you can smuggle it into stuff
you know like an english class or a
history class but
um i don't think we're ever really going
to see it become part of the
school curriculum here in the united
states sadly to say right
um
let's see what else we got here uh
mark says has there been any incentive
initiative to get feedback from parents
and students about
things do they want to go back to
face-to-face sessions or is it just the
institute's making decision on behalf of
all that's a great question
so again no continuity
no uniformity each of these are doing
their own thing right
so i have seen some schools
claim for example carthage college that
students want this that they've done
polling among the students
i don't know if it's true i don't know
if they pulled 10 students or
100 students they didn't they didn't
release that information
they just said we're making this this
these decisions marquette did this too
marquette said oh yeah the students are
totally in favor of this
talking with students um myself and so
this is purely anecdotal
they don't seem so jazzed about going
back to school
except my daughter of course who's like
i can't wait to get the hell out of
indiana
and up here to milwaukee and like get on
with my life
no longer in in high school and now i'm
in college
right but that may that may fade fairly
quickly too i i don't know
um so yeah i i
i would like to say that we actually had
some sort of sentiment testing but
i don't think there's anything that's
really going on with that you know
so all right i think i may have missed
somebody some reading up
um
oh tara asks a good question what are
your thoughts about a statewide mandate
for
virtual public education so if you mean
like a state that we have
here in the united states like wisconsin
it's just not going to happen
we don't we don't have the political uh
will to do that we're
we're effectively gridlocked right now
like i said the republicans control the
legislature
because of gerrymandering gerrymandering
so bad that the case actually went to
the supreme court and then the supreme
court decided again
dominated by republicans not not to take
the case
so we're stuck with this this really
screwed up uh
system the wisconsin legislature has not
met for months because the republicans
are unwilling to do anything so
we don't have the political capacity to
to do statewide mandates really for
anything right now
other states maybe they could you know
and and you'd be talking about blue
states
because the red states are the ones
where they're like let's open everything
so i mean you could do it like in
massachusetts maybe
um new york could be tough jersey would
be
tough um california is such a
such a big mess anyway i don't know that
they could do it so
i i don't know i think it's kind of a a
non-starter here
in the united states unfortunately and
since we have
almost zero you know no useful
leadership
at the federal level when it comes to
this um until betsy devos is out of the
department of education
i don't know what we're gonna we're
gonna do so
yeah let's see if there's anybody else
that i i missed
uh bank bono kazuzi do i have a video
teaching prison teaching in prisons part
two
now i never did a follow-up on that i'll
i'll probably have to
i'll probably have to do some about that
especially since i'm i'm still teaching
in prisons now but i'm doing it remotely
through the second chance pell program
uh through milwaukee area technical
college
anybody else that i missed
mark said behavior of staff and
bureaucrats as setting is
an example to students which i feel is
component to education that element
shouldn't be
overlooked well the example that they're
setting is
we're going to have our meetings about
you going face to face remotely
but you're going to go face to face so
the example is
we're going to make the decisions for
you but we're not going to actually like
live up to that stuff ourselves because
we're high risk you know and what what
example does that provide well
functioning adults are hypocrites and
everybody should like be out for
themselves
if we're going to treat this present
generation the way that we are
we shouldn't be surprised when when
we're old people and they're like
screw you you know it won't be screw you
boomers because the boomers are
dying out it'll be screw you jet xers we
don't need you
you know let's put you out on the ice um
if that's if that's what we're gonna
accept for for them
all right let's see if we've got some
other uh stuff here
thomas has a kind of uh uh
off topic thing but i'll i'll answer it
what's my favorite drink to have in a
bar how much can i bench i don't know
because i
when i do machines when i'm working out
um
i'm always i'm always a little bit uh
suspicious of people who think that how
much you can bench is an important thing
um i like you know i actually like to
drink beers and i used to brew beer
quite a bit myself for for years and i
live in a great place for
local craft beers we have one of the
oldest american craft breweries here
in wisconsin in milwaukee the sprecker
brewery which recently
was sold as the original founders
changed hands
so um all right
uh
retro gamer the american catholic
institution has much to offer the
dialogue about right reason as a moral
agenda
saint henry newman's canonization is a
testament to the cultural reverence of
scholars
yeah i guess i mean most catholic
schools are not really catholic
quite frankly i mean marquette it bills
itself as a jesuit school
you would never guess by the the the
decision-making processes that they go
through
um and the the veneer is very very thin
these days and it's also reflected in
how they've changed the core
you know we're down to just one
philosophy class and one theology class
in the core
used to be you had to take you know a
number of them and this is the case for
a lot of catholic institutions they're
not really catholic in any
any genuine sense any organic sense you
might say
which is uh unfortunate but what are you
going to do
you know i guess you got to look for
alternative institutions
you know do the do the benedict option
but not the rod drear
benedict option but the genuine you know
uh benedict option that that
mcintyre was sketching out uh david says
uh you've spoken to your favoriting of
physical books over ebooks for obvious
practical benefits but how do you look
ethically at the pirating of ebooks
for the financially fraud or e-textbooks
i i frankly i i don't i don't have any
problem with uh textbooks being
he pirated that's i i would say you know
in a sort of deontological way well it's
still wrong
but it's it's so much less wrong
given all the other things that go into
it than
other things that i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna care likewise i don't care when i
see
that um uh um
philosophy documentation center uh or
elsevier
um journals get pirated
they can you know if they have a problem
with with that given all the profits
they're making
they can handle it i i care much more
about the the little person
and how they're being affected um now if
we're talking about like
ebooks being pirated uh not e-textbooks
but like
you know like let's say somebody writes
a great e-book about i don't know
the good life right should you be
pirating that i would say no no you
actually should pay the royalties to the
author now when we get to things like
you know books that are put out by clue
or brill
and they cost like 200 bucks for the
book
there i care less right but if it's like
you know some
some person wrote a book that's their
passion and they they published it on
amazon self-publishing i don't want to
get them
see them getting screwed so i would make
i'd make some pretty big
distinctions there you know
uh and foamy some interesting questions
here
do you think automating some subjects
could be of use and what about outdoor
classes over loudspeakers
i think i saw a story on india doing
that so
outdoor classes um
[Music]
that can work in temperate zones
you know it's interesting i'm seeing
these places that are doing outside
classes
and they're like in new england and i'm
like
how the hell is that going to work come
november you know you're going to be
outside
i don't i don't get how this is going to
happen maybe maybe then the thing to do
would be like to have
here i mean here's an idea that nobody
seems to have tapped yet
so what if we actually had for each
classroom we did we socially distanced
we wear masks but we all have mics
now granted you have to clean up the
mics after each use and stuff like that
mics and and like headsets and we're all
on one
uh channel and we find a way to filter
out the coughs and the
heavy breathing and stuff like that that
people would do
uh maybe you need a sound person to
handle that but you could you could have
uh some of those sorts of uh
things going on right um i don't know
maybe that maybe that's a way to make it
feasible
automating subjects i'm not sure what
automating means
um so i think that you can certainly
develop
educational resources that could be
shared like videos
if that's what you mean by automating
that's been going on for quite a while
right
um
let's see what else we've got here uh
some discussion about peripatetic
education so the peripatetics
aristotelians right aerosol used to walk
back and forth as he lectured parapatine
um but again it's it's tough to do that
once it starts to turn winter here in in
wisconsin
um and and you know i think with these
outside things you might also have some
issues
of accessibility you know students can
be subject some students might be
subject to
uh um allergies when it's hay fever
season
you know there's issues that we'd have
to like work out
uh kyle have you noticed any differences
between your students in prison versus
university in terms of attitude towards
coursework
uh no it's really about the same i would
say uh you have
you have kind of a bell curve right most
of the students will do most of the work
and they won't do a great job on
on everything and then you have like the
real go-getters
give me more work let me do everything
as as you know as well as i can and then
you have
the slough-offs on the other side or
they're like no matter
what you do they're gonna they're like
destined to fall themselves through the
cracks because they don't want to do any
of the work and when they do it it's
gonna be shoddy and stuff like that
and you have the same issues like
plagiarism arising
um or or trying to cheat you know at
about the same rates i'd say
you know um so i
i had a couple cases of academic
dishonesty
but i i always have some cases in the
other places where i'm teaching
so all right um
here's an interesting point by lyle
himself there's tons of stuff online
being pirated and the online economy is
doing great in booming so i don't think
pirating stuff is a problem
you can save the money to support small
content creators
that's actually a great the second part
i really like right
so instead of it being like oh i'm gonna
pirate stuff and then
you know screw the system man you know
i'm i'm just going to be a consumer you
help out the smaller
uh groups sort of like what i was saying
you know
so we did this uh on the river west
radio
show wisdom for life dan and i in
episode 19
which was about moving from rights to
responsibilities and thinking about free
speech
we were talking about um
[Music]
you know a practice if you think that
that that
a conversation is not worth engaging in
then
then you know the person's going to be
arguing in bad faith just disengage
but then you can use that time and
attention and devote it to a better
conversation
right so what you're talking about here
is kind of similar
if you're going to save money by not
paying for textbooks that are just going
to support
you know mcmillan or paul grave or
whoever
uh maybe save that money and do spend it
on small
content creators you know buy some some
ebooks from somebody
who uh is writing some some decent stuff
or you know
i don't chip into somebody's patreon for
their podcast or
things along those lines i think that's
that's actually you know
we could generalize this and say it's
not just
enough to to do x maybe we we ought to
be reallocating
priorities you know the point i was
making on a larger scale about
education and where we spend our money
but maybe we can do that on a micro
level too
all right um
let's see here well
we're getting close to the end of the
time i think i've answered
everybody's comments and
questions the ones that are actually
relevant to the
uh the situation um and
and the topic obviously i'm not doing
too much
about other uh things having to do with
uh
um working out because this isn't really
about that
um anything else that people
want to bring up or should we close this
out here
i allocated 90 minutes for this i got to
do a lot of stuff today
um so maybe maybe we'll just uh end it
here i'm glad that people
enjoyed the discussion a lot of great
proposals a lot of really good ideas
coming out of the woodwork here now
getting them to policy makers
that's a bit tougher that is the
challenge but
um gotta think a bit more about that
all right so i'm gonna say goodbye to
everybody and
um what else do we have coming up next
next week obviously the classic metal
class
on saturday and then i'm going to be
having my birthday bash
online on sunday in part because we
thought the democratic national
convention was going to be
here with biden now it's not going to be
and we weren't sure about what internet
access would look like on my actual
birthday
so all right that's it
uh from my end and i'll see all of you
somewhere else in another discussion